uh before I jump into today's lecture I
wanted to answer a few questions people
emailed me saying they had questions
about the last lecture they ran on time
for so if you have a question about we
covered last time I'm welcome to answer
it now starting with you it should be on
I think you now hear me now maybe you
can ask them to turn on hopefully
they'll come on anybody else yes ah so
once let's know smidge on line was uh
how do I identify the market has a fat
growth rate
now and also the next ten years all
right so the question is how you
identify markets that are growing
quickly the good news about this is this
is one of the big advantages students
have you should just trust your
instincts on this oldest people have to
basically get about the technologies
that are sort of the young people using
right because young people get older and
they become the dominant market but you
can just watch what you're doing what
your friends are doing and you will
almost certainly have better instincts
on fast-growing markets than anybody
older than you and so the answer to this
is just trust your instincts think about
what you're using more think about what
you're using what you're seeing people
your age begin to start using that will
almost certainly be the future maybe I
can do one more question on the last
lecture before we start this is really
less about others online you will burn
out while she'll yeah sure
the question is how you deal with
burnout as a founder I this the answer
to this is just that it sucks and you
keep going unlike a student or you can
sort of like throw up your hands and say
you know what I'm really burned out I'm
just going to like get bad grades this
quarter one of the hard parts of our
running startup is that it's real life
and you just have to get through it the
canonical advice is like go on vacation
or whatever that never works for
founder's is sort of all-consuming in
this way it's very difficult to
understand so what you do is you just
keep going you rely on people it's like
really important and Founder depression
is a serious thing and you need to have
support network but the way through
burnout is just to address
just address the things that are going
wrong and you'll eventually feel better
all right so last week we our last
lecture we covered the idea in the
product and I want to just emphasize
again that if you don't get those right
none of the rest of this is going to
save you today we're going to talk about
how to hire and how to execute hopefully
you don't execute the people you hire
sometimes so first I want to talk about
co-founders co-founder relationships are
among the most important in the entire
company and everyone says that you need
to watch out for tension brewing among
co-founders and address it immediately
methyl true and certainly in ycs case
the number one cause of early death for
start-up is co-founder blow ups but for
some reason a lot of people treat
choosing their co-founder with even less
importance than they put on hiring don't
do this this is one of the most
important decisions you make in the life
of your startup and you need to treat it
as such and for some reason students are
really bad at this they just pick
someone that like I want to start a
business you want to start a business
let's start it starts together there are
these like co-founder dating things
where you're like hey I'm looking for a
co-founder we don't really know each
other let's start a company and this is
like crazy um you would never hire
someone like this and yet people are
willing to choose their business
partners this way it's really really bad
and choosing a random co-founder or
choosing someone you don't have a long
history with choosing someone that
you're not friends with so that when
things are really going wrong you have
this sort of past history to bind you
together usually ends up in disaster
we had one wife feedback where nine of
about 75 companies added on a random
co-founder between when we interviewed
the company is the one they started and
all nine of those teams fell apart the
next year the track record for founders
that don't already know each other is
really bad a good way to meet a
co-founders in college if you're not in
college and you don't know a co-founder
the next best thing I think is to go
work an interesting company if you work
at Facebook or Google or something like
that it's probably almost as co-founder
rich as Stanford it
has no co-founder then have a bad
co-founder but it's still bad to be a
solo founder I was just looking at the
staff here before we started for the top
and I may have missed one because I was
coming quickly but I think but for the
top 20 most valuable YC companies all of
them have at least two founders and we
we probably fund at a rate of something
like 1 out of 10 solo team so best of
all founder you know co-founder you know
better than that
or not as good as that but still okay
solo founder random founder you meet and
get the students do this for some reason
really really bad uh so if you're
thinking about co-founders and people
that could be good there's a question of
what you're looking for right and I see
we have this public phrase and it's
relentlessly resourceful and everyone's
heard of that and I think that really is
a very good description for what you're
looking for with co-founders you
definitely need relentlessly resourceful
co-founders but there's a more colorful
example that we share at the YC kickoff
Paul Graham started using this and I've
kept it going so you're looking for
co-founders that need to be unflappable
tough they know what to do in every
situation they act quickly their
decisive they're creative they're ready
for anything and it turns out that
there's a model for this in in pop
culture and it sounds really dumb but
it's at least very memorable and we've
told every class of YC just for a long
time and I think it helps them and that
model is James Bond and again this
sounds crazy but it I will at least
stick in your memory and and you need
someone that behaves like James Bond
more than you need someone that is you
know an expert in some particular domain
as I mentioned earlier you really want
to know your co-founders for a while
ideally years this is true for early
hires as well but incidentally more
people get this right for early hires
than they do for co-founders so again
take advantage of school in addition to
relentlessly resourceful you want a
tough and a calm co-founder there are
all the obvious things like smart but
everyone knows that you want a smart
co-founder most people don't prioritize
tough and calm
well enough especially if you feel like
you yourself aren't you need a
co-founder who is if you're not
technical and hopefully most people in
this room are you really want a
technical co-founder there's this weird
thing going on starts right now where
it's become popular to say like you know
what we don't need technical founders
we're going to hire people we're just
going to be great managers that doesn't
work too well in our experience you know
software people really should be
starting software companies media people
should be starting media company
so in a YC experience two or three
co-founders seems to be about perfect
one obviously not great five really bad
for work sometimes but two or three I
think is what's the target
okay the second part of how to hire try
not to so one of the weird things that
you'll notice if you start a company is
it everyone asks you how many employees
you have and this is the metric people
use to sort of judge how real your
startup is and how cool you are and if
you say you have a high number employees
they're really impressed and if you say
you have a low number employees then
then you sound like sort of this little
joke but actually it sucks to have a lot
of employees and you should be proud of
how few employees you can have lots of
employees ends up with things like a
high burn rate and you're losing a lot
of money every month complexity tension
flow decision-making the list goes on
but it's nothing good so you want it you
want to be proud of how much you can get
done with a small number of employees
many of the best YC companies have had
phenomenally small number of employees
for the first year sometimes none
besides the founders they really try to
stay small as long as they possibly can
at the beginning you should only hire
when you have a desperate need to later
you need to learn how to hire fast the
scale of the company but in the early
days the goal should be not to hire not
to hire and one of the reasons this is
so bad is that the cost of getting an
early hire wrong it's really high in
fact a lot of the companies that I've
been very involved with that have had a
very bad first hire in the first three
or so employees never recover from it
just kills the company Airbnb spent five
months interviewing their first employee
before they hired someone and in their
first year they only hired two people
before they hired a single person they
wrote on a list of the cultural values
that they wanted any Airbnb employee to
have one of those is that you had to
bleed Airbnb and if you didn't sort of
agree to that they just wouldn't hire
you as an example of how intense Brian
Chesky is he's the Airbnb CEO he used to
ask people before he hired them at
Airbnb if they would take the job if
they got a medical diagnosis that they
had one year left to live he wanted them
to be back committed later he decided
that was like a little bit too crazy and
I think he relaxed it to ten years but
last I heard he still asked that
question but like you know these hires
really matter these people are what go
on to define your company and so you
need people they believe in it almost as
much as you do and it sounds like a
crazy thing to ask but he's gotten this
culture of extremely dedicated people
they come together when the company
faces the crisis and when the company
faced a big crisis early on everyone in
the company lived in the office and they
ship product every day until the crisis
was over one of the remarkable
observations about Airbnb is if you talk
to any of the first say I don't know 40
or 50 employees they all feel like they
were part of the founding of the company
and this is really hard to get right and
this is really rare but by having an
extremely high bar I'm hiring slowly and
making sure everyone believes in the
mission you can get that okay so let's
say you know you've listened to the
warning about not hiring and now you
absolutely have to when you're in this
hiring mode your job it should be your
number one priority to get the best
people just like when you're in product
mode that's your number one priority and
when you're fundraising mode fundraising
is your number one priority one thing
that founders always underestimate it's
how hard it is to recruit you know you
can hear this great idea everyone's
going to kind of join but that's not how
it works to get the very best people
they have a lot of great options right
and so it can easily take a year to
recruit someone it's this long process
and you have to convince them that your
mission is the most important of
anything that they're looking at this is
another case of why it's really
important to get the product right
before anything else the best people
know that they should join a rocket ship
by the way that's my number one piece of
advice if you're going to join us
start up pick a rocketship pick a
company that's already working and that
them you know not everyone yet realizes
that but it's you know you know because
you're paying attention that's going to
be huge and again you can usually
identify these but good people know this
right and so good people will wait and
they want to see that you're on this
breakout trajectory before they join one
question that people asked online this
morning is how much time you should be
spending hiring the answer is either
like 0 or 25% you're either not hiring
at all or it's probably your single
biggest block of time in practice like
all these books on management or
whatever say that you should spend 50%
of your time hiring but the people that
give that advice it's rare for them to
even spend 10% themselves 25% is still a
huge amount of time but that's really
how much you should be doing once you're
in hiring mode ok
so if you compromise and hire someone
mediocre you will always regret it we
always like to warn founders of this no
one really feels it until they must make
the mistake the first time but it can
poison the culture mediocre people at a
big company caused some problems they
don't usually kill the company a single
mediocre hire in the first five will
often in fact kill a start-up a friend
of mine has a sign up in the conference
room that uses for interviews and he
like positions designs that the
candidate is looking at it while they're
interviewing and it says that mediocre
engineers do not build great companies
yeah that's true
it's really true you can get away with
it in a big company right because people
just sort of like false to crack but but
every person in a start-up sets the tone
so if you compromise in the first you
know say 5 10 hires it might kill the
company and you should think about that
for everyone you hire like will I bet
the future of this company on the single
hire and that's a tough bar at some
point in the life of the company when
you're bigger you will compromise on a
higher there will be some pressing
deadlines or something like that you
will still regret it but this is the
difference between theory and practice
and we're going to have later speakers
talk about what this HAP what the new
one that's happens but in the early days
you just can't screw it up
sources of candidates this is another
thing that students get wrong a lot the
best source by far for hiring is people
that you already know and people that
other employees in the company are you
know most great companies in tech have
been built by personal referrals for the
first at least hundred employees and
often many more most founders feel
awkward about calling everyone good that
has ever met and asking their employees
to do the same but you'll notice that if
you go work at Facebook or Google one of
the things they do in your first few
weeks with an HR person see you down and
like beats out of you every smart person
you've ever met no matter how likely you
think you are to be able to recruit them
and these personal referrals really are
the trick to hiring so you have to let
go way beyond your comfort zone here
another tip is to look outside the
valley it is brutally competitive hire
engineers here but you probably know
very good people living elsewhere in the
world they would love to work with you
another question that founders ask us a
lot about is experience how much that
matters the short version here is that
experience matters for some roles and
not others when you're hiring sort of
like you know someone that is going to
run a large organization of your company
experience probably matters a lot for
most of the early hires you make in the
startup experience doesn't matter very
much and you should go for attitude and
belief in what you're doing most of the
best hires that I've ever made in my
entire life have never done that thing
before so it's really worth thinking
like is this a role where I care about
experience or not most the time you
don't in there in the early days there
are three things that I look for when I
hire people are they smart do they get
things done I do I want to spend a lot
of time around them and if I get an
answer if I get it ended up with a yes
for all three of these I've almost never
regretted the hire it's almost always
worked out you can learn a lot about all
three of these things from an interview
but the very best way is by working
together so ideally it's someone you've
worked with in the past and in which
case you probably don't even need an
interview if you have it
then I think it's way better to work
with them on a quick project for a day
or two before hiring them you'll both
learn a lot they
- and most first-time founders are very
bad interviewers but very good at
evaluating someone after they've work
together so one of the pieces that we
give advice one of the pieces of advice
that we give at YC is try to work
together on a project rather than just
doing an interview if you are going to
interview which you'll probably do as
well you should ask specifically about
projects that someone has done in the
past you'll learn a lot more than you
will with brain teasers for some reason
young technical founders love to ask
brain teaser questions rather than just
ask what someone's done really dig into
projects people have worked on and call
references that is another thing that
first-time founders like to skip you
want to call some people that these
people have worked with in the past and
when you do you don't just want to
aspect oh how would so and so like you
really want to dig in like is this
person in the top 5% of people you've
ever worked with what specifically did
they do would you hire them again like
why why aren't you trying to hire them
again
you really have to press on these
reference calls another thing that I've
noticed from talking to a lot of YC
companies is that good communication
skills tend to correlate really well
with hires that work out I used to not
pay attention to this we're going to
talk more about why communication is so
important in early startup if someone is
difficult to talk to if someone cannot
communicate clearly it's a real problem
in terms of their likelihood to work out
also for early employees you want people
that have somewhat of a risk-taking
attitude you you generally get this or
they wouldn't be interested in startup
but now that startups are sort of more
in fashion you you want people that
actually sort of like a little bit of
risk if someone's choosing between like
McKenzie and joining your startup very
unlikely that that person is going to
work out at the startup you also want
people who are maniacally determined and
that is slightly different than having a
risk tolerant attitude so you really
should be looking for both by the way
people are welcome to interrupt me with
questions as stuff comes up there's a
famous test from Paul Graham called the
animal test
and and the idea here is that you should
be able to describe any employee as an
animal at what they do and I don't think
that probably translates out of English
very well but you know you need
unstoppable people you want you want
people that are just going to get it
done
founders that end up being really happy
with their early hires usually end up
describing these people as the very best
in the world whatever they do
Mark Zuckerberg once said that he tries
to hire people that a he would spend
time with socially and B that he'd be
comfortable reporting to if the roles
were reversed this strikes me as a very
good framework you don't have to be
friends with everybody but you should at
least enjoy working with them and if you
can't have that you need to at least
deeply respect them but again the if you
don't want to spend a lot of time around
people you should sort of trust your
instincts on that while I'm on this
topic of hiring I want to talk about
employee equity founders screwed us up
all the time I think that is a rough
guideline you should aim to give 10% of
the company but the first 10 employees
they have to earn it over four years
anyway and if they're successful they're
going to contribute way more than that
they're going to increase the value of
the company by way more than that and if
not then they won't be around anyway so
for whatever reason founders are usually
very stingy with equity to employees and
very generous with equity to investors I
think this is totally backwards I think
this is one of the things that founders
screw up the most often you know
employees will only add more value over
time investors sort of like write the
check and then despite a lot of big
promises don't usually do that much
sometimes they do but but your employees
are really the ones that build the
company over years and years so I
believe in like fighting with investors
to reduce the amount of equity they get
and then being as generous as you
possibly can with employees the YC
companies that have done this well the
YC companies that have been super
generous with equity to early employees
in general are the most successful ones
that we funded all right
so one thing that Saunders forget is
that after they after that they hire
employees they have to retain them I'm
not going to go into a huge amount of
detail here because we're going to have
a full lecture on this later
but I do want to talk about it a little
bit because founders guess what's wrong
so often you have to make sure that your
employees are happy and feel valued this
is one of the reasons that the equity
grants are important people in the
excitement of joining the startup don't
think about it much but as they come in
day after day year after year if they
feel like they've been treated unfairly
that will really start to grate on them
and resentment will build but more than
that learning just a little bit of
management skill which first time CEOs
are usually terrible at goes a long way
one of the speakers at YC this summer
who who is now extremely successful but
struggled early on and had his team
turnover a few times someone asked him
what his biggest learning was he said
that it turns out you shouldn't tell
your employees they're sucking up every
day unless you'd like them all to leave
because they will but as a founder this
is this like very natural instinct right
you think you can do everything the best
and it's easy to tell people when
they're not doing it well so learning
just a little bit here will prevent this
like massive team churn it also doesn't
come naturally to most founders to
really praise their team it took me a
lot of times to you have to let your
team get all the credit for everything
good that happens and you take
responsibility for the bad stuff you
have to not micromanage you have to like
continually give people new areas of
responsibility these are not the things
that most founders think about I think
the best thing you can do is be aware
that is the first time founder you are
likely to be a very bad manager and try
to overcompensate for that Dan pink
talks about these three things that
motivate people to do great work
autonomy autonomy mastery and purpose I
never thought about that when I was
running my company but I thought about
it since and I think that's actually
right and I think it's worth trying to
think about that it also took me a while
to learn to do things like one-on-ones
and give clear feedback all of these
things that first-time CEOs just don't
do until they get burned a few times but
maybe
maybe I can save you from doing that
alright and the last part for on the
teen section is about firing people when
it's not working
no matter what I say here this is not
going to prevent anyone from doing it
wrong and the reason is that firing
people is one of the worst parts of
running a company actually in my own
experience I think it is the worst every
first-time founder waits too long
everyone hopes that an employee will
turn around but the right answer is to
fire fast when it's not working out it's
better for the company it's also better
for the employee but it's so painful and
so awful that everyone gets it wrong the
first few times in addition to firing
people who are doing bad at their job
you also want to fire people who a
creating an office politics and B who
are persistently negative the rest of
the company is always aware of employees
doing things like this and it's just
this huge drag it's completely toxic to
the company again this is an example of
something that might work ok in a big
company although I'm still skeptical but
will kill a start-up so I think you need
to watch out for people that aren't yet
making your employees you like your
security is you also feel like they're
out the door yeah sure so the question
is how do you balance firing people fast
and making early employees feel secure
the answer is the when an employee is
not working it's not like they screw up
once or twice
anyone will screw up once or twice or
more times than that and you know you
should be like very loving not take it
out on them like be a team work together
if someone is getting every decision
wrong that's one you need to act and at
that point it'll be--it'll be painfully
aware to everyone it's not a cases if
you screw up it's a case where every
time someone does something you would
have done the opposite yourself you
don't get to make their decisions but
you do get to choose the decision-makers
and if someone is doing everything wrong
just like a consistent thing over like a
period of many weeks or months you'll be
aware of it this is one of those cases
where inquiry it sounds complicated to
be sure what you're talking about and in
practice there's almost never any doubt
it's the difference between someone
making one or two mistakes and just
constantly screwing everything up or
causing problems or making everyone
unhappy is is painfully obvious the
first time you see it yeah
flounders the Cylons equity split great
question when should co-founders decide
on the equity split for some reasons
I've never really been sure why this is
a lot of founders a lot of co-founders
like to leave this off for a very long
time you know they'll even sign the
incorporation documents in some crazy
way so they can wait to have this
discussion this is not a discussion that
gets easier with time you want to set
this ideally you know very soon after
you start working together and it should
be near equal if you're not willing to
give someone your co-founder you know
like an equal share of the equity I
think that should make you think hard
about whether or not you want the native
co-founder but in any case you should
try to have the ink dry on this before
the company gets too far along like
certainly in the first number of weeks
yeah okay but then how do you know if
it's going to be crippling and aspire
that way the question is I said that
inexperience is okay how do you know if
that's going to you know someone's going
to scale past not scale up to a role as
things go on and later become crippling
people that are really smart and they
can learn new things can almost always
find a role in the company as time goes
on you may have to move them into
something else something other than
where they started you know it may be
that you hire someone to leave the
engineering team that overtime can't
scale as you get up to 50 people and you
give them a different role really good
people though can almost always find
some great place in the company I have
not seen that be a problem too often
down the other thing goes this way all
right the question is what happens when
your relationship with your co-founders
falls apart we're going to have a
session on mechanics at the near the end
of the course but here is the most
important thing that founders screw up
which is every found every co-founder of
you
yourself of course have to have vesting
basically what you're doing with
co-founder vesting is your pre
negotiating what happens if one of you
leaves and so the normal stance on this
in Silicon Valley is that it takes four
years let's say you split the equity
50/50 it takes four years during all of
that and the clock doesn't start until
one year in so if you leave after one
year you keep 25% of the equity if you
leave after two years 50 and on like
that if you don't do that and if you
have a huge fall out and one founder
leaves early on with half the company
you have like this dead weight of it on
your equity table and it's very hard to
get investors to fund you or to do
anything else so number one piece of
advice to prevent that is to have
vesting on the equity we pretty much
won't fund a company now where the
founders don't have vested equity
vesting equity because it's just that
bad the other thing to do is as soon as
problems come up in the relationship
between the co-founders which happens to
some the green every company talked
about it early don't let it just set off
their investor for years if you have to
choose between hiring a suboptimal
employee and losing your customers to a
competitor what do you do if it would be
one of the first five say employees of a
company I would lose those customers I
just I think the damage that it does to
the company you know you don't want to
it's better to lose some customers than
kill the company later on I might have a
slightly different opinion but it's
really hard to say in the general case
how about one more question I keep going
yeah what to experience is school and I
learned wasn't it seeing the patient I'm
going to get to that later the question
is what about co-founders aren't working
in the same location don't do it I am
skeptical of remote teams in general but
in the early days of a startup where
communication and speed outweigh
everything else for whatever reason
video conferencing or calls just don't
work that well the day
this is look at the say like 30 most
successful software startups of all time
and try to point to a single example
where the co-founders were in different
locations it's really really tough all
right we'll skip a little bit of this
all right so now we're going talk about
execution execution for most founders is
not the most fun part of starting a
company but it is often the most
critical most people that start a
company think that they are signing up
to have this brilliant idea and you know
then they're just going to like be on
magazine covers and go to parties but
but really what it's about more than
anything else what what being a founder
means it is signing up for this year's
long grind on execution and you can't
outsource this the way to have a company
that executes well is to execute well
yourself everything in a startup gets
modeled after the founders whatever the
founders do becomes the culture so if
you want a culture where people work
hard and pay attention to detail and
focus on the customer and are frugal you
have to do it yourself there is no other
way you cannot hire a CEO and have them
you know do this while you go off to
conferences the company just needs to
see you is like this maniacal execution
machine as I said in the first lecture
there's like a hundred times at least
more people with great ideas than people
that are willing to put in the effort to
X keep them well ideas by themselves not
worth anything
only executing well is what what adds
value or what creates value a big part
of execution is just putting the effort
but there is a lot you can learn about
how to be good at it and so we're going
to have I think three classes that just
talk about this so the CEO people have
asked me a bunch of times like the jobs
at the startup CEO and there are
probably more than five but you know
here are five that comp a lot in the
early days the first four I think
everyone thinks of the CEO jobs sets a
vision raise money evangelize the
company to people you're trying to
recruit existing employees partners
press customers everybody hire and
manage the team but the fifth one
is that studying the execution bar and
this is not something that most founders
get excited about or think about
themselves doing but I think is actually
one of the critical CEO roles and no one
but the CEO can do this execution gets
divided into two two key questions one
can you figure out what to do and two is
can you get it done so I want to talk
about two parts of getting it done
assuming that you've already figured out
what to do and those are focused in
intensity so so focus is critical one of
my favorite questions to ask founders is
what they're spending their time and
their money on this reveals almost
everything about what founders think is
important one of the hardest parts about
being a founder is that there are a
hundred important things competing for
your attention every day and you have to
identify the right two or three work on
those and then ignore or delegate or
defer the rest and a lot of these things
that that founders think are really
important you know interviewing a lot of
different law firms going to conferences
recruiting advisors whatever they just
don't matter
right and what really does matter varies
with time but it's an important piece of
maeda advice you need to figure out what
the two or three most important things
are and then just do those and you can
only have two or three things every day
because everything else will just come
at you now fires of the day and if you
don't get really good at setting what
these two two or three priorities are
every day you'll never be great at
actually getting stuff done this is
really hard for founders right founders
are people that get excited by starting
new things
unfortunately the trick to great
execution is to say no a lot you know
you're saying no 97 times out of 100 and
most founders signs that they make a
very conscious effort to do this most
startups are not nearly focused enough
they work really hard maybe but they
don't work hard on the right things and
you'll still fail one of the great and
terrible things about starting a
start-up is that you get no credit for
trying
you only get points when you make
something that the market won so if you
work really hard on the wrong things no
one will care so then there's this
question of how do you figure out what
to focus
each day and this is where it's really
important to have goals most good
founders that I know at any given time
have a small number of overarching goals
for the company everybody in the company
knows could be things like shipper
products by this date you know maintain
this growth rate get this certain
engagement rate higher for these key
roles get this deal done but anybody
could tell you in the company every week
what are our what are our key goals and
then everybody executes based off of
that the founder really does set the
focus whatever the founder cares about
whatever the founders think are the key
goals that's going to be what the whole
company focuses on and the best founders
repeat these goals over and over far
more often than they think they should
need to they put them up on the walls
they talk about them and one-on-ones
all-hands me in every week but it keeps
the company focused one of the keys to
focus and why I said I think co-founders
different places struggle is that you
can't be focused without really great
communication even if you only have say
four or five people in a company a small
communication breakdown is enough for
everybody to be working on slightly
different things and then you lose focus
in the company just scrambled I'm going
to talk about this a little bit more
later but growth and momentum are
something you can never lose focus on
growth and momentum are what a start-up
lives on and you always have to focus on
my paying these you should always know
how you're doing against your metrics
you should have a weekly review meeting
every week and you should be extremely
suspicious if you're ever talking about
we're not focused on growth right now
we're not growing that well right now
but we're doing this are saying you know
we don't have we don't have a timeline
for when we're going to ship this
because we're focused on this other
thing we're doing a rebrand whatever
almost always a disaster so you want to
have the right metrics and you want to
be focused on growing those metrics and
having momentum don't don't let the
company get distracted or excited by
other things a common mistake is that
companies get excited by their own PR
it's really easy to get PR with no
results
and it feels like you're actually really
cool but in a year you'll still have
nothing and at that point you won't be
cool anymore and you'll just be talking
about these articles from a year ago
that oh you know like these fanfic stews
and start this new startup it's going to
be the next big thing and now you have
nothing and that sucks
um and then as I mentioned already be in
the same space this is like I think this
is pretty much a non starter remote
co-founding teams is just really really
hard it slows down the cycle time more
than anybody everything that's going to
the other piece
besides focus for execution is intensity
startups only work at a fairly intense
level a friend of mine says that the
secret to startup success is extreme
focus and extreme dedication you know
you can have like a startup and one of
those things and have a startup in a
family here but you probably can't have
many other hobbies startups are not the
best choice for work-life balance and
that's sort of just the sad reality
there's a lot of great things about a
startup but this is not one of them
they are all consuming in a way that is
difficult to explain you generally need
to be willing to outwork your
competitors the good news here while
that's hard to see is it a small amount
of extra work on the right thing makes a
huge difference one example that I like
to give is thinking about the viral
coefficient for a consumer web product
how many users how many new users each
existing user brings in if it's 0.99 the
company will eventually flatline and
then die and if it's 1.01 you'll be in
this happy page place of exponential
growth forever so this is just one
concrete example of where a tiny bit of
extra work is the difference between
success and failure and when we talk to
successful founders they tell stories
like this all the time you know just out
working their competitors by a little
bit was what made them successful so you
have to be really intense you know this
only comes from the CEO this only comes
from the founders one of the biggest
advantages that startups have is
execution speed and you have to have
this relentless operating rhythm
Facebook has this famous poster that
says move fast and break things but at
the same time they manage to be obsessed
with quality and this is why it's hard
it's easy to move fast or be obsessed
with quality the trick is that you have
to do both at a startup you need to have
a culture where people have very high
quality standards for everything the
company does but still move quickly
Apple Facebook and Google have all done
this extremely well it's not just about
the product it's about everything they
do they move fast and they break things
and they're frugal in the right places
but they care about quality everywhere
you know you don't buy simplicity
computers if you don't want them to
write shitty code you really have to you
do have to set a quality bar that runs
through the entire company related to
this is that you have to be decisive
indecisiveness is a start-up killer
mediocre foundries spend a lot of time
talking about grand plans but they never
quite make this decision you know
they're they're talking about well I
could do this thing that sounds greater
I could do this other thing and they
keep going back and forth and they don't
act and what you actually need is its
bias towards action the best founders
work on things that seem small but they
move really quickly they get things done
really quickly every time you talk to
the best founders they they've gotten
new things done in fact this is the one
thing that we learned best prediction
success of founders in YC if every time
we talk to a team they've gotten new
things done that's the best predictor we
have as a company we'll go on to be
successful part of this is that you can
do huge things by in incremental pieces
if you just keep knocking down small
chunks one at a time in a year you look
back and you've done this amazing thing
on the other hand if you disappear for a
year and you expect to come back with
something amazing all at once it usually
never happens so you have to pick these
right sides projects you know even if
you're building this crazy synthetic
biology company most people would say
well I have to go away for a year I
can't do this incrementally there's
almost always a way to break it down in
smaller projects so speed is this huge
premium right the the best founders
usually respond to email the most
quickly they make decisions
quickly they're generally quick in all
these different ways and they just have
to do whatever it takes attitude they
also show up a lot they come to you know
they come to meetings they come in
they've any different person one piece
of advice that I have that's always
worked for me is they they get on planes
in marginal situations how we doing on
time
I'll tell a quick story here when I was
running my own company we found out that
we were about to lose a deal it was sort
of this this critical deal from the
first big customer in the space and it
was going to go to this company that has
been around for years before we were and
they had this like all locked up so we
call this at hey we have to start
property you gotta meet with us
they said you know what we're signing
this deal tomorrow sorry we drove to the
airport we got on a plane we were at
their office at 6 a.m. the next morning
we just sat there they told us to go
away we just kept sitting there finally
one of the junior guys decided to meet
with us finally after that one of the
senior guys decided to meet with us they
ended up ripping up the contract of the
company and we closed the deal with them
about a week later and I'm sure that had
we not gotten on a plane have we not
shown up in person that would not have
worked out and so you just sort of like
you show up you do these things you know
it's when people say get on planes in
marginal situations they usually mean it
they don't usually mean it literally but
I think it's actually good literal
advice all right
skip to that part then so I mentioned
this momentum and growth earlier once
more that momentum and growth are the
lifeblood of startups this has been
probably in the top three secrets XK
mean well you want a company to be
winning all the time if you ever take
your foot off the gas pedal things will
spiral out of control
snowball downwards a winning team feels
good and keeps winning I seem that
hasn't won in a while get to be
motivated and keep losing so always keep
momentum is this prime directive for
management startup if I can only tell
founders one thing about how to run a
company it would be this
for most start software startups this
translates to keep growing for hardware
startups it's translates to don't let
your ship date slip this is what we tell
people during YC and they usually listen
everything is good what happens after
the end of YC is that they get
distracted on other things and then
growth slows down and somehow after that
happens people start getting unhappy and
quitting and then everything falls apart
it's hard to figure out a growth engine
because most companies growing new ways
but there is this thing know that if you
build a good product it will grow and so
getting this good this product right at
the beginning it's the best way to not
lose momentum later if you do is lament
them most founders try to get it back in
the wrong way they give these long
speeches about vision for the company
and they try to rally the troops with
speeches but employees in a company
where momentum has sag don't want to
hear that you have to save the dition
speeches for when the company is winning
when you're not winning you just have to
get momentum back in small wins a board
member of mine used to say that sales
fix everything in a start-up and that is
really true so you figure out where you
can see small wins and you get that done
and then you'll be amazed how all the
other problems in the startup disappear
another thing that you'll notice if you
have momentum sag is that everyone
starts disagreeing about to do twice
come out when a company loses momentum
and so a framework for that that I think
works is the one there's disagreement
among the team about what to do then you
ask your users and you do whatever your
users tell you and you have to remind
people like hey stuffs not working right
now we don't actually hate each other we
just need to get back on track and
everything will work and if you just
call it out if you just acknowledge that
you'll find that things get way better
to use a Facebook example again when
Facebook's growth slowed in 2008 mark
instituted a growth group they worked on
very small things to make Facebook grow
faster all of these by themselves seems
really small but they got the the curve
a Facebook back up it quickly became the
most prestigious group there Marcus said
that it's in one of Facebook's best
innovations according to friends of mine
that worked at Facebook at the time it
really turned around the dynamic of the
company and I went from this thing where
everyone was feeling bad and momentum
was gone back to a place that was
winning so a good way to keep momentum
is to establish an operating rhythm in
the company early where you ship product
and launch new features on this regular
basis where you're reviewing metrics you
know every week with the entire company
this is actually one of the best things
your board can do for you
boards add value to business strategy
only rarely but very frequently you can
use them as a forcing function to get
the company to care about metrics and
milestones one thing that often disrupts
momentum and really shouldn't is
competitors competitors making noise in
the press I think probably crushes a
company's momentum more often than any
other external factor so here's a good
rule of thumb don't worry about a
competitor at all until they're actually
beating you with a real shift product
press releases are easier to write some
code and that is still easier than
making a great product so remind your
company of this and don't this is sort
of a founders rule is not to let the
company get down because the competitors
in the press this great quote from Henry
Ford that I love the competitor to be
feared is one who never bothers about
you at all what goes on making his own
business better all the time these are
almost never the companies that put out
a lot of press releases and they bump
people out should we move on to the
section you know what we'll cover this
in a later lecture I will talk about
Finance you'll make in a distribution
are there any questions okay so on this
Paul Graham is going to see see you then
thank you
you